I've been asked again to make a special
announcement special announcements of
the winners there's a Frenchman at the
stage door offering to pay 43 dollars an
ounce for your Oscars
what's an awful lot like Charles
DeGaulle and now to continue and now to
continue the drain on our gold supply
here is a beautiful young actress who
once co-starred with me in a picture and
a handsome young actor who never got
that kind of break but made it anyway
elke sommer and Richard Crenna
the men we now honor the sound effect
specialists are those dedicated
technicians whose job it is to make sure
you never fall asleep in the theater and
nominated for the best achievement in
sound effects our John pointer for the
Dirty Dozen and James a Richard for in
the heat of the night you do the honors
okay all right now Sheila opened the
envelope
how do softly quickly all right and the
winner is John pointer for the Dirty
Dozen
John Boehner mr. Keith Olson John John
is very sorry that he was not able to be
here tonight but he asked me to thank
all the members of the Academy for this
wonderful Oscar and a special thanks to
mr. Robert Aldrich and everybody at MGM
for all the help thank you